[Música]
a 10 años del accidente en lact mecantic
el tren de carga sigue pasando en pleno
centro de la ciudad la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
atenderá el caso del pueblo wetten
cbc radio Canadá y el gobierno
canadiense suspenden sus publicidades en
Facebook e Instagram
y ovación de pie en Montreal para el
maestro Chucho Valdés
[Música]
Bienvenidos a su podcast la actualidad
canadiense en 10 minutos del equipo
latinoamericano de radio Canadá
internacional en esta primera semana de
Julio Les saluda con el gusto de siempre
Paloma Martínez Estos son nuestros
principales temas
a 10 años del accidente en la megatic el
tren de carga sigue pasando en pleno
centro de la pequeña ciudad en la
provincia de Quebec la desviación de la
vía férrea reclamada por varios vecinos
divide ahora la población su coste se
estima en cerca de mil millones de
dólares los que piden su construcción
creen que si la Circunvalación hubiera
existido las 47 víctimas mortales del
accidente del 6 de julio del 2013
seguirían con vida recordemos que en la
noche del 5 al 6 de julio del 2013 un
tren sin conductor transportando
petróleo crudo se descarriló y explotó
en pleno centro de la pequeña ciudad
se encuentra a 250 kilómetros al este de
la ciudad de Montreal el tren que
transportaba 72 vagones cisterna de
crudo había quedado estacionado en la
vía principal de otra comunidad nantes a
12 kilómetros al noroeste de la megatic
la agencia Federal de seguridad en el
transporte de Canadá concluyó
posteriormente que el maquinista del
tren Tom harding había puesto muy pocos
frenos de mano antes de irse a pasar la
noche a un hotel cuatro minutos antes de
la una de la madrugada del seis de Julio
el tren comenzó a rodar cuesta abajo
hacia la megantic aumentando la
velocidad cuando tomó una curva y se
salió de la vía férrea el Primer
Ministro de Canadá invitó a todos los
canadienses a recordar a quienes
perdieron trágicamente la vida hace diez
años en una entrevista con radio Canadá
y usted entró recordó que cuando el
accidente sucedió él comenzaba su
mandato como jefe del partido liberal y
que prometió que si llegaba a ser Primer
Ministro haría mucho para mejorar las
condiciones de seguridad para los trenes
de carga cerca de las regiones pobladas
por las que pasan prometió también que
una desviación para la vía férrea sería
construida
es una promesa que hice entonces que
impediríamos que los trenes siguieran
pasando por el centro de la ciudad han
pasado diez años y siguen pasando somos
conscientes de que está tardando mucho
pero es un arduo proceso esperamos poder
empezar las obras de la desviación este
otoño para acabar de una vez con este
problema pero al mismo tiempo hemos
hecho mucho en materia de seguridad
ferroviaria y hemos aumentado la
seguridad en todo el país No solamente
en la Megan
eran las palabras de Justin Primer
Ministro de Canadá
[Música]
en otros temas la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
atenderá el caso del pueblo wet en 2019
la primera nación de la provincia de
Columbia británica se opuso la
construcción del gasoducto koston
gaslink en su territorio ancestral el
pueblo indígena wetzuten había
establecido puestos de control y
bloqueado las vías férreas de Canadá
paralizando el transporte de mercancías
en todo el país los puestos de control
fueron desmantelados durante varias
operaciones policiales el 10 de julio
próximo durante una audiencia virtual la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos examinará el trato dispensado
por Canadá y por la provincia de
Columbia británica a la primera nación
huixtlam Durante los actos de oposición
a la construcción del gasoducto que
atraviesa sus tierras tradicionales
el periodista de la cvc Duncan Mau
explica por qué Columbia británica es un
campo de batalla por los derechos
territoriales indígenas en el país
Colombia became a problems and from se
trata de una historia muy antigua en
Colombia británica nos estamos
remontando a 1871 que es cuando ese
territorio se convirtió en una provincia
la provincia la colonia en ese momento
decidió que el título de propiedad
indígena el derecho de los indígenas a
la tierra no existía en la década de
1870 recordemos que los buscadores de
oro estaban llegando y pasando a través
de la provincia rumbo a yukón en ese
momento se decidió Qué derechos tendrían
los indígenas sobre la Tierra y la
provincia de Columbia británica decidió
que el título territorial indígena no
existía y ese ha sido el problema en esa
provincia durante más de 150 años
el periodista de la
cdcábamos es indígena anishinabe miembro
de los chipeguas de la primera nación de
La Isla Georgina en el sur de Ontario
[Música]
esta semana cdc radio Canadá y el
gobierno canadiense suspendieron sus
publicidades en Facebook e Instagram se
trata de una respuesta a la decisión de
la empresa matriz de esas plataformas
meta de bloquear la distribución de
contenidos periodísticos en desafío a la
ley de noticias en línea c18 adoptada
por el parlamento canadiense la nueva
ley canadiense quiero obligar a los
gigantes digitales a compartir los
ingresos de la distribución de sus
contenidos con los medios de
comunicación del país
cbc radio Canadá grupos mediáticos
quebecenses como quevecori cocheco y el
diario laprés anunciaron el miércoles
que dejarán de comprar publicidad en las
redes sociales Facebook e Instagram
la ciudad de Montreal anunció lo mismo
el ministro canadiense del patrimonio
Pablo Rodríguez dijo que su gobierno
suspendió toda la publicidad en Facebook
e Instagram en el marco de su batalla
sobre la ley de noticias en línea contra
Los Gigantes tecnológicos Google y meta
Facebook
ha decidido ser poco razonable e
irresponsable Y ha empezado a bloquear
noticias canadienses por eso hoy
anunciamos que el gobierno de Canadá
suspenderá todas sus publicidades en
Facebook e Instagram Google por su parte
se ha mostrado abierto encontrar una
solución y esto es exactamente lo que
esperamos de ellos hoy hacemos un
llamamiento a ambas plataformas meta y
Google para que permanezcan en la mesa
de discusión trabajen en el proceso de
regulación con nosotros contribuyan con
su parte justa y mantengan las noticias
en sus plataformas es bueno para las
plataformas mismas para la información
en Canadá para los canadienses y sobre
todo para nuestra democracia
eran las palabras de Pablo Rodríguez
ministro canadiense del patrimonio
[Música]
y finalmente esta semana les Hablamos de
una ovación de pie en Montreal para el
maestro Chucho Valdés
[Aplausos]
El virtuoso pianista cubano se presentó
este jueves en el marco del Festival
Internacional de jazz de Montreal el
gigante Chucho Valdés de 81 años optó
por hablar únicamente en español en el
teatro mesoneer de la plaza de zar donde
sacó de su público tan ecléctico como
sus ritmos carcajadas bailes y una
ovación de pie que lo impulsó a hacer no
Uno sino dos encores
nuestra colega Gabriela Gucci está
preparando una reseña completa para
ustedes la podrán consultar así como
todos nuestros otros contenidos
informativos en nuestro sitio internet
radio guión canadá.sea barra oblicua rsi
barra oblicua e.s
quiero contarles algo la primera vez que
yo toqué en este festival
de Montreal
fue exactamente hace 30 años
esto es todo por nuestra parte en esta
ocasión Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
En nombre del equipo latinoamericano de
radio Canadá internacional Paloma
Martínez les desea un buen fin de semana
y será hasta la próxima
[Música]